hey girl you said ted is your new best
friend but michael is mine okay as you
can see i still have on my louis vuitton
bag my nba louboutin collab right that's
right this is another one of those bags
so let's let's show them before we get
to the shoes let's show them what's
special about this bag besides the fact
that lebron owns it okay well that's the
biggest thing but this is an nba uh
collab with louis vuitton
virgil ablo influenced but lebron
carries it and when you see him usually
carrying it yeah you know you see the
nba players walking through the tunnel
that's where they show off their look
it's like their little runway and then
this bag actually punches out you can
put your basketball right here
you know you have to be carrying your
bag and your balls
on the details okay the size bags we've
got shoes because you can't talk about
basketball season march madness nba
playoffs coming up without talking about
sneakers so let's do it what do you have
well we got some yeezys right here i got
some of course and they're my size yes
we made sure that okay look at that
these are the gatorade
i love these okay explain these please
these are the dog walkers and uh this is
you can see they stepped in something
look at that they have the little sparky
tag on the back they come with an actual
poo poo bag so it comes attached and you
can zip her in and put that inside that
is so cool we gotta love nike for their
creativity right because look at these
these are earth day sneakers obviously
earth day is coming up this month
actually these are not nike these are
adidas but that's because you have it
all okay yeah those are all made of
you know uh recycled product that is so
dope um yeah i know you picked these out
these i want okay these are one we'll
talk we'll have to talk about that later
but beside okay let's let's move on now
because we have about a minute left i
want to make sure i get this in you know
when you're buying sneakers you have to
make sure that they are authentic
because there's nothing worse than
walking around with fake jordans okay so
how do you guys make sure that they're
real well everything we do from watches
to jewelry to handbags to sneakers is
about authenticity we usually have
third-party authentication
we use gia for diamonds we have watch
csa for watches
we use a device called entropy okay and
it looks like an ipod but it actually
takes photos all the way down to the
microfiber with bags and sneakers
and it shoots all those photos up to a
database uses artificial intelligence
comes down
if it's authentic it'll give us an
opportunity to print this card that
comes with all our bags as you can see
there you go that's what you got to look
for when you come in here and when
people do walk in what is the process
really quick like what do they need to
know before they come in well you know
if you have something that's not
authentic we offer free authentication
to the public so you may have a gift at
home that you're not aware of but it's
super simple it usually happens in 15
minutes or less and we're happy to help
out but more importantly we like to sell
with the thought of everything being
authentic yes and
pre-loved pre-ladies is what we're all
about and coming up you guys later in
the future of max pond okay it's max lux
fyi this is your this is your pre-love
luxury cars everything that you can
think of right so we're we're opening
our brand we're opening more stores and
we'll have cars and fine art and more so
well i'm sure we will check in with you
then as well thank you so much thank you
mike i'll send it back to you i'm gonna
go shopping now i was gonna say shopping
sports rocky's having a fun day out
there thank you so much rocky all right
mercedes we'll send it over to you
thanks jillian